shall we begin the Game of Thrones
season 7 premiere kicked off in the most
incredible way possible a viciously
satisfying opening scene and a cameo
from none other than Ed Sheeran a toast
that's Walder Frey hosting his guests at
a celebratory dinner you're my family
the man who helped me slaughter the
stocks at the red wedding but we soon
realized things weren't exactly as they
seemed that you didn't slaughter every
one of the stocks yep that would be Arya
getting some seriously sweet revenge
[Music]
when people ask you what happened here
tell them the North remembers tell them
winter came for house free another major
moment Ed Sheeran's cameo his angelic
voice catches Arya's attention as she's
riding through the forest four hands
[Music]
it's a pretty song
I've never heard it before it's a new
one ET spoke with Edie last month about
his experience filming the show I didn't
put on my thermal socks and I was
outside in the winter in England for
about ten hours so it was cold
[Music]